notre histoire commence le 29 août
dernier lorsque l'on découvre ces images
choquantes enregistrées par une caméra
de surveillance à Cannes on y voit une
femme de 89 ans en train de se faire
violemment agresser par trois jeunes
âgés de 14 à 15 ans montant du vol
seulement 10 euros cette agression
suscite alors très vite l'émotion et
fait le tour des chaînes info violent
agression qui suscite l'indignation ce
matin dans une interview diffusée par
BFM l'octogénaire a pris la parole c'est
un 3 en colère est-ce que c'est leur
faute
alors cet agression le maire de Cannes
David Linard réagit 3 jours plus tard
s'il s'agissait de ma mère qui avait été
ainsi agressé c'est peut-être moi qui
serait aujourd'hui en prison une sortie
qui a beaucoup fait réagir et vous êtes
vous choqué par les propos du maire de
Cannes
s'il vous plaît êtes-vous choqué par les
propos du maire de Cannes moi je suis je
lis voilà je sais que ça va peut-être ok
moi je suis je suis assez d'accord avec
ce qu'il a dit le maire de Cannes aussi
merci c'est ça parce qu'on voulait
absolument que tu sois là ce soir parce
que on se rappelle de l'histoire d'Ali
on a reçu ici tu es son neveu et c'est
vrai que tant pour y croire que tu dises
non je suis pas choqué au contraire mais
au contraire c'est tout le contraire
toi tu étais tu trouves voilà faut pas
se faire justice soi-même non
complètement pas c'est justement un peu
moins c'est comme un combustible en fait
on explique aux gens qu'il faut faire
justice soi-même c'est n'importe quoi
alors qu'on peut le penser on le pense
tous mais nous on est des adultes et les
adultes faut faire preuve de raison les
envies c'est les enfants et là en
l'occurrence ils avaient 14 ans
Raymond toi tu es pas du tout d'accord
ce qu'il dit c'est vrai que les envies
en mémoire mais moi si je tombe au même
moment qui sont en train de faire ça à
ma grand-mère ou à ma mère je suis comme
lui je vais en prison on a des droits on
est aussi des devoirs et ton devoir
c'est pas de dire ça à la télé c'est à
dire que les gens quand ils entendent ça
veut dire c'est un peu tu cautionnes non
tu touches à ma mère j'ai le droit de te
défoncer
je défends une réaction que j'aurais pu
avoir
je suis obligé d'être honnête je vais
pas te dire s'il y a des mecs s'il y a
des mecs de 14 ans qui sont en train de
taper à ma mère au sol ma grand-mère au
sol je vais pas passer en disant les
gars je vais porter plainte tout de
suite je reviens sur le jeu
je te parle comme je le pense là tout de
suite je dis que moi sans donner de
hiérarchie au vol aux banditisme ou à la
crasse ou pour moi c'est la pire des
races les les mecs qui tapent les les
petites vieilles en sac à main c'est la
pire des races sont tout en bas surtout
en bas c'est la pire le feu ça brûle ça
c'est c'est évident
on va pas on va pas le laisser faire qui
va faire ça sauf que à un moment donné
on est doté de raison et on peut pas
dire la télé encore moins quand on
représente la République je me ferai
justice moi-même c'est du délire alors
c'est du délire
et oui j'ai pas envie là Jean-Michel moi
j'ai peut-être honte de le dire mais si
ma fille ou mon fils se faisait ma fille
je prends l'exemple de ma fille parce
qu'elle est plus jeune se faisait violer
tuer je ferai tout pour tuer son
agresseur
je le dis une fois qu'on a fait et ben
c'est pas grave c'est dans tout jusqu'à
la fin de ma vie d'accord
même chose de ma vie que de me dire que
le mec il est peut-être en train en
prison en train de
YouTube entre la paix ses potes non je
voudrais qu'il meurt voilà je suis
désolé c'est comme ça après comme on
empêche ça serait peut-être bien que mon
empêche mais je ferai tout pour le faire
effectivement une chose de le dire est à
raison on va pas se mentir moi la
première si on touche à mon fils et ben
c'est pas grave je me dis je me dis pour
foutu de toute façon ma vie est foutu
donc moi j'irai en prison voilà mais là
on parle d'un élu de la République c'est
pour ça que je dis oui mais bon parce
que la République c'est pas il doit
passer toutes les émotions parler comme
vous êtes à l'ancienne je pense moi je
pense qu'au contraire ce que veulent les
gens ce que veulent les gens aujourd'hui
est-ce que veulent les c'est ce que
veulent les Français ils veulent qu'un
élu de la République il arrête de parler
comme un élu de la République je suis
désolé
il a parlé avec son cœur il a il a parlé
avec l'émotion c'est ce qu'on aime dans
sur un c'est ce qu'on veut chez un début
de la République aussi on en a marre
qu'il fasse des discours tout fait
Valérie Bénaïm excusez-moi
il l'a pas parlé il l'a écrit c'est
alors il a parlé avec émotion et moi je
préfère un élu de la République qui a de
l'émotion et qui dit des choses plutôt
qu'un Élie de la Rép qui dit toujours
politique qui arrive sur les les les
attentats sur des choses graves qui sont
passés écouter on va faire le maximum on
en a marre on veut des mecs qui parlent
avec eux on veut des mecs qui parlent
avec leur truc désolé
ça après je dirais voilà on a pas j'ai
pas voulu dire ça mais voilà mais au
moins il parle avec émotion je suis
désolé des enfants de 14 ans qu'on
banaliser la violence parce que il faut
dire par les émotions euh tout ce qui se
passe la télé c'est violent chaque fois
qu'on allume la force vidéo c'est
violent tout est violent des enfants ils
font la violence la langue de bois aussi
aussi je vous dis et si tout allait bien
dans la société on a des droits
aussi
parce que les paroles ils n'ont pas
éduqué
ça j'en ai marre ça fait des années que
je l'entends donc il y a des parents qui
aiment les enfants et d'autres qui les
aiment faire et d'autres qui les
éduquentes quand tu habites dans des
dans des milieux défavorisés tes PARENTS
tu les vois même pas il part tu dors il
rentre tu dors et donc c'est la faute
c'est des parallèles comme ça est-ce que
j'ai dit que c'était la faute j'ai dit
qu'il faut pas dire que c'est la faute
des parents
lui ce que veut dire aussi depuis tout à
l'heure
aussi pour que les allocations on retire
nanana il a quoi voir les parents
là-dedans s'il vous plaît aussi s'il
vous plaît aussi une qui veut dire
surtout c'est qu'il faut pas se faire
justice soi-même ça on est tous d'accord
là-dessus après on parle d'une phrase
d'un élu sur Twitter sur les réseaux
sociaux il a parlé avec émotion juste
aussi qui vient de dire aussi et ça
c'est de débat il était partout est-ce
que c'est la faute des parents on
rappelle que ces enfants avaient 14 ans
on va voir le témoignage de de du fils
de Angel dans un instant et sa petite
fille vous allez voir que ils sont
extrêmement énervés Daniel alors moi je
trouve que l'attitude de la muscléaire a
été bonne de bout en bout j'adore le
fait qu'ils disent minable parce que il
y en a marre de prendre des pincettes
avec des gamins de 14 ans qui sont
capables de taper comme ça une
grand-mère je suis désolé c'est fini les
pincettes c'est fini
donc très bien il est d'accord il a il
reste
horrible c'est affreux tous les
onomatopées que vous voulez pas de souci
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait vrai question
il y en a marre comme le dit Cyril des
gens qui viennent après les attentats on
condamne et puis il rentre chez eux il y
a plus rien là il sait bouger comme
jamais et il faudrait que tout le monde
fasse à moi il y a un ami m'a envoyé un
texto à monsieur qui connaît de 76 ans a
eu la même chose que lui il y a pas
d'image il y a pas un maire qui va faire
du bruit ça devient voilà c'est tous les
jours et on s'en [ __ ]
c'est très bien moi j'ai parlé l'autre
fois de Far West je me suis fait tomber
dessus là on est dans le Far West il y a
pas de Chérif et ben voilà il faut y
aller je suis désolé c'est fini de
prendre des vacances
quand on dit faut y aller il faut faire
quoi un enfant de 14 ans on ne sait rien
Mathieu Delorme qu'est-ce qu'on fait
vous me répondez
sur le fait qu'effectivement Mathieu
le problème c'est que ce que tweet là où
il est important c'est qu'il est en
train de dire que aujourd'hui justement
on ne se sent plus protégé et le jour où
dans un pays dans chaque personne veut
soi-même s'auto protéger c'est le moment
où effectivement on est plus dans une
démocratie mais effectivement au pays
par complètement complètement sucette et
aujourd'hui beaucoup de policiers vous
disent les gens cherchent à s'armer
eux-mêmes des armes des machins sur
internet je vous dis la vérité
j'y pense et tout ça quand on a peur et
qu'on se sent plus protégé par sa police
c'est là où il y a un vrai souci et le
souci il est que Sega man 14 ans eux ne
se sentent pas concernés par la justice
donc oui effectivement pardon il est en
train de montrer que il y a un véritable
problème aujourd'hui dans ce pays c'est
pas question ne sont pas concernés par
la justice ils ont même pas conscience
de la justice c'est encore plus grave
mais non c'est parce que eux ils se lève
le matin il y a que de la violence
partout partout un moment donné un
mensonge répété mille fois devient une
vérité pour eux la violence fait partie
de leur quotidien
c'est de la violence ils allument BFM
c'est la violence c'est de la violence
pour eux ils sont banalisé la violence
prémédité qu'il a pensé il va faire
aussi on va on va accueillir René et
Alicia c'est le fils et la petite
vidangel la retraite agressée on va pour
mettre la vidéo de ce qui s'est passé
ils vont rentrer pendant ce temps et moi
j'ai vraiment envie d'entendre leur
témoignage ce soir voilà et dans quel
état d'esprit ils sont regardez cette
vidéo voilà qui qui est objectif
regardez
merci merci aussi mais mettez-vous là
aussi merci en tout cas
prenez Ginola d'être avec nous vous êtes
le fils d'Angèle merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui René il fallait que
j'attendais manière j'aurais bien voulu
qu'elle soit elle va arriver votre NES
elle est sur le chemin elle va arriver
dans un instant Alicia qui sera là dans
quelques minutes
qui a parlé bien sûr prenez
vous par contre ouais alors René
justement moi je veux avoir votre avis
parce que je vous demande de parler un
peu fort parce que j'ai des problèmes
auditifs alors il y a pas de problème
déjà première question comment elle va
votre maman
c'est à dire elle va comment elle est là
elle est sortie aujourd'hui elle est
avec ma sœur en bas qui s'occupe d'elle
ses petits-enfants quand même qui
s'occupent d'elle parce que moi je suis
dans le Var et aller les tambins donc
c'est beaucoup ma nièce justement qui va
arriver qui va arriver qui s'occupe bien
de ses papiers et tout et qui a eu qui a
eu un rapport avec la police et tout
quand ça s'est passé comment comment
vous l'avez appris moi je l'ai appris
parce que ma sœur m'a téléphoné en me
disant maman s'est fait agresser et
quand j'ai vu la photo
pas possible quand vous avez vu la photo
elle fait rien là-dedans il y a pas
assez de c'est moi je suis pas
je sais pas trop m'exprimer mais prenez
moi votre émotion elle est je vous ai vu
tout à l'heure en loge mais vite tout de
suite j'ai besoin de parler j'ai besoin
de m'exprimer moi votre émotion elle
touche tout le monde là je vous dis on
n'a pas besoin de de longues
ils auraient pu prendre le sac à main
sans la frapper vous avez la violence du
cookies le mec dessus mais c'est pas
avoir des couilles des trucs comme ça et
l'autre il filme il filme il filme le
conneries qui font et vous voulez pas
avoir la haine vous que si vous voulez
devant le mec je l'ai tue tous les trois
moi je dis la même chose que vous mais
je vous le dis mais je voulais dire un
truc je vais en prison j'y vais en
prison volontiers pour ma mère
faut arrêter déjà les retirer de
l'argent rien du tout ça c'est sans
arrêt qui a des trucs comme ça
aux parents vous en voulez à qui pardon
j'en voulais aux parents de ces ados
quand même parce que ils sont pas suivi
ces jeunes qui sont vous les voyez à 14
ans ils sont dans la rue là ils traînent
à minuit un truc
attendez vraiment à mon époque ça se
passait pas comme ça à telle heure il
fallait être à la maison et puis c'est
tout et il y avait pas d'agression comme
ça on allait il y avait des bagarres il
y avait des trucs mais pas des trucs
comme ça pour moi
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans quel état
d'esprit il y a pas c'est pas
pardonnable je regrette même que ça soit
des enfants de 14-15 ans mais quand ils
en arrivent à faire des actes comme ça
pour moi pour moi il y a pas de il y a
pas d'excuses il y a pas d'excuse alors
il paraît j'en ai fait dans ma vie des
conneries moi mais des trucs comme ça
jamais des allez s'entraîne à des proies
faciles comme ça mais c'est trop facile
il est très sur 15 m pour leur prendre
les sacs et les trucs il se passe il y a
trop de il y en a trop de trucs
je sais pas qu'est-ce que vous avez dit
la police
la police vous savez ce qu'elle fait
elle les attrape ils ont elle a pas le
temps de les monter au tribunal qui sont
relâchés ces jeunes
mais ils sont relâchés moi je suis des
collègues qui sont dans la police ils me
l'ont dit me dire on est
on n'est pas arrivé on n'est pas
redescendu au poste ils sont dehors
parce qu'ils sont mineurs mais en
attendant la responsabilité il apprenne
d'aller frapper une personne
âgée en plus par le pape Luc à une
personne 89 ans qui tient à peine debout
allait y mettre un coup avait les
langues comme millimètre derrière la
tête mais c'est pour la tuer c'est pour
la tuer
parce que vous aurez moi quand j'ai vu
les premières photos
j'ai dit ma mère elle est morte elle est
morte
aujourd'hui vous entendez voilà aussi
une qui disait au contraire faut pas se
faire vengeance soi-même c'est ce que
disait Valérie Benaim également
vous attendez quoi là aujourd'hui vous
vous avez envie de faire quoi vous avez
envie vous dites quoi vous envie d'être
auprès de votre maman lui dire voilà
c'est de la réconforter vous allez avoir
peur maintenant chaque fois qu'elle va
bien sûr qu'elle a peur les trucs il y a
le TF1 qui m'a parlé qui ont essayé de
l'appeler parce qu'il voulait la voir on
a dit non laissez-la tranquille à la
pauvre elle a pas besoin de trucs elle
sort à peine
il y a mon petit neveu avec
c'est sûr qu'elle a la trouille c'est la
deuxième fois la deuxième fois elle a eu
une petite agression une il y a deux
trois ans de ça c'était deux nanas
qu'elle a vu bon il y a pas eu de il y a
pas eu de coups ils ont pris le truc et
puis le porte le sac et ils ont reposé
plus loin quoi un truc mais bon il y a
pas eu d'agression mais dans le même
immeuble en plus alors il paraît que
vous a proposé de l'argent non ça c'est
pas vrai c'est vrai ça ou pas
entendu ça elle a dit d'ailleurs ma
nièce va le dire bien sûr parce que bon
elle avait perdu parce qu'elle quand
elle est tombée elle a cru qu'elle était
tombée ah oui quand les pompiers sont
arrivés ils ont dit non mais non madame
vous êtes pas tomber on vous a agressé
parce qu'elle était par terre elle avait
perdu un peu la connaissance et elle
pourrait même était tombée euh tout
simplement et c'est les pompiers qui ont
dit non non vous avez été agressé après
il y a la police qui est venue après
manière c'est plus au courant que moi
là-dessus parce que c'est ce qui vous a
dit votre maman après une fois qu'elle a
su qu'elle s'était fait agresser
quel état d'esprit la pauvre même pas
elle était massive vous la connaissez ma
mère elle est tellement connue en bas
elle avait un petit restaurant
elle est bien avec tout le monde c'est
c'est elle en veut même pas elle a dit
quoi non non personnellement elle a dit
ou bien là qui est venue elle a dit
c'est des petits jeunes avant mais ce
truc mais bon on peut pas passer on a
dit on peut pas passer à côté c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible pas pour une
histoire de tout c'est de vengeance ou
quoi c'est que c'est pas que pour ma
mère c'est pour d'autres personnes aussi
qui peuvent se faire agresser donc il
faut que ça bouge il faut que il faut
que ça monte le plus haut possible
qu'ils aient qui est quand même plus de
de
fermeté ou ou je sais pas mais il faut
faire à quelque chose il y a pas
possible c'est quoi votre message
vous voudriez quoi en fait mais moi je
voudrais que quand même soyez que j'ai
une qui soit puni mais vraiment puni pas
qu'il soit relâché du jour au lendemain
comme ils ont mais qui est quand même
une
d'ailleurs le j'approuve je voudrais
remercier le maire de Cannes bien sûr
et sur le coup de la colère il a dit
comme moi que si il les avait sur la
main et il y en a qui sont pas d'accord
avec eux les gens qui sont choqués par
cette phrase comme aussi qu'est-ce que
vous leur dites
je sais plus quoi dire
je suis tellement fâché à l'intérieur
des trucs
comment réagir à des trucs comme ça
c'est pas possible il y en a qui tirent
les yeux qui disent
c'est pas grave c'est bon c'est pas
possible
c'est sûr c'est facile à dire quand
c'est pas sa mère
on se le prend derrière à la tronche et
puis voilà quoi donc il faut il faut que
il faut que le président ou un truc qui
fasse quelque chose pour ces trucs là
qu'ils aient qu'ils aient je sais pas
moi qui soit qui trouve une sanction
quand même
vous savez René vous savez vous auriez
envie de parler aux parents de de ces
agresseurs
je vais leur dire qu'ils ont des enfants
ils savent pas s'en occuper et qui font
des enfants ou alors ils font des
enfants pour toucher les pour toucher
les tous les aides qu'ils ont et puis
passe en occuper après c'est tout
qu'est-ce que je voulais vous dire
je voulais voyez sont à la rue ils sont
à minuit vous les voyez trainer dans les
rues vous allez détruire
pour les laisser traîner comme ça dans
la rue il faut s'en occuper des petits
cantons les prendre Daniel et parce que
aussi a dit quelque chose tout à l'heure
en disant mais moi je trouve que c'est
du mépris par tous les parents qui
parfois même des mères célibataires qui
arrivent très bien à élever leurs
enfants avec même très peu de moyens
donc ça c'est un mépris je suis désolé
pas toujours une question il y a des
fils de riches qui font des conneries
aussi bien sûr donc c'est pas une
question de c'est bon d'excuser les les
parents qui n'auraient pas de moyens et
moi ce que je dirais à ceux qui sont
contre cette phrase et qui ont été
choqués c'est attendant de voir ce que
vont avoir ces gamins et est-ce que vous
pensez la vraie question je sais est-ce
que vous pensez que des enfants de 14
ans qui ont fait ça sont récupérables ça
c'est la vraie question pour moi
on n'est pas dans un débat le témoignage
de René et Alicia qui nous a rejoint
Alicia vous êtes la petite fille
d'Angèle vous occupez même allez mettre
en prison tout ça c'est pas non plus la
solution alors attendez chez le maire de
cas c'est le maire de Cannes s'il vous
plaît j'ai David Lisnard qui m'appelle
en direct David qui est là qui m'appelle
on dirait qu'il doit nous regarder
bonsoir bonsoir David bonsoir Cyril ça
va bien David vous devez nous regarder
nous sommes en direct de vous
appeler
[Musique]
reliquement bien sûr en saluant
et toute votre équipe
sur
que vous avez rappelé de ma part elle
est en réponse à un internaute qui me
disait Monsieur le Maire on vous a pas
entendu sur ce dossier et donc c'est le
cinquième tweet de il y a 4 trucs qui
précède
dès qu'on a eu des images
on a grâce à un très très
bon transmis des coordonnées à la police
nationale on sait bien encore donné quel
polic Ier les trois gamins donc
celui
qui lui parce qu'il y a une autre vidéo
pas celle-là ça c'est la vidéo la
surveillance mais on entend les gamins
et commenter la chute de la victime donc
on était interpellés
le bon équilibre entre et ne pas
apparaître comme récupérons
quelque chose
c'est
rappeler humaine
ment et je confirme je l'assume
calmement que si
on prend la mer
mes enfants
[Musique]
et de la loi du talion au personnel la
preuve c'est que dans ce que j'ai écrit
je dis
je dis pas que chacun règle ses comptes
et on le laisse faire
on sera en prison mais j'assumerai mon
inconnu
de citoyens il y a fortiori quand on est
élu et de toujours rappeler
que la viande c'est un autre sujet
parmi ce que j'en pense mais je crois
que c'est facile à comprendre et puis
ensuite
[Musique]
règle
demande compte personnel
tant
[Musique]
que la mer je voulais juste vous dire ça
merci
il s'agit surtout pas de faire une
apologie du règlement personnel
malheureusement beaucoup trop mais à un
moment donné je suis
avant d'être élu je serai pas être là
pour avoir été je suis un être humain et
c'est pas tombé dans la facilité de le
dire c'est tout simplement une réalité
voilà je veux pas merci beaucoup David
merci en tout cas
merci vous aussi merci
elle est très résistante elle est sortie
aujourd'hui de l'hôpital merci David
merci de nous avoir appelé merci
beaucoup David merci merci merci c'était
David Lisnard de canne donc qui nous
appelle en direct c'était pas du tout
prévu donc il nous regardait apparemment
voilà où son équipe a dû lui dire nous
sommes également avec Alicia Alicia de
songeur petite fille d'Angèle nièce donc
de de René vous vous êtes vous étiez où
au moment de l'agression au travail où
vous apprenez ça commence et si vous
êtes très proche de votre grand-mère
c'est comme votre mère je sais donc là
c'est comme René c'est comme vous vous
éclatez en sanglot vous non même pas
c'est l'adrénaline du coup je vais à sa
résidence d'accord et là on vous raconte
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
qu'il faut que je retourne voir le poste
parce que pour voir les vidéos il faut
que je sois accompagné de la police quoi
alors on va revoir le témoignage de la
de la maman de la droite de votre maman
René qui a parlé cet après-midi sur BFM
c'est vrai voilà c'est vrai que c'est
elle est tellement touchante regarde
les pompiers mais je sais pas et c'est
là les pompiers qui suis tombé les
pompiers me dis donc j'ai rien fait moi
ce jeune ils étaient trois je sais pas
pourquoi bon je sais pas trop en colère
parce que est-ce que c'est leur faute
votre parent c'est pas son jeu avec 15
ans
[Musique]
voilà quand on la voit on a envie on a
envie de la serrer dans nos bras c'est
vrai qu'on
chante
elle est tellement touchante
est gentil dans le meilleur des mondes
et quoi est-ce que est-ce que vous aviez
une colère comme comme Rony quand vous
avez appris ça pas du tout parce que
René on le voit là il nous a dit oui
mais j'aimerais que ça fasse plus bouger
en fait c'est à dire en fait on commence
jeune quoi des enfants c'est jeune quoi
14 ans c'est jeune mais vous avez envie
de leur dire quoi est-ce que vous avez
déjà envoyé une solution
à trouver où je suis pas pour la prison
donc je vais pas vous parler de prison
mais peut-être il faut les mettre dans
des camps peut-être je sais pas mais
pourquoi mais regarde trop le jeu vidéo
je sais pas moi
c'est un truc ce monde entre eux
trouver une solution pour d'autres
personnes
[Musique]
après moi je suis pas pour ne pas une
nouvelle si si vous appelez vous leur
diriez quoi les parents j'ai pas envie
de les avoir en fait d'accord voilà moi
non plus
sauver leur gosse de cette société parce
que dans 5 ans ils font quoi ils
plantent les gens parce qu'on en
étiquette
je veux pas savoir qui c'est je ne veux
pas les voir
c'est des parents qui sont déjà et puis
pour moi ils sont pas intéressants ils
sont pas intéressant parce que je sais
même pas si je sais même pas si les
jeunes les jeunes qui ont fait le
l'attentat ils ont un regret d'avoir
fait ce qu'ils ont ils ont fait ce que
dit Alicia ils n'ont pas de regrets bien
voulu avoir une réponse là-dessus ils
ont mis longtemps quand ils ont été
devant les policiers à reconnaître leur
culpabilité ils ont mis longtemps au
début
14 ans oui on est chez nous tous ils ont
reconnu finalement d'ailleurs ils seront
jugés le 30 novembre et risque la prison
très franchement risque la moitié de la
peine encore eu par un donc il risque
trois ans et demi de prison possible
c'est vrai est-ce que ça c'est une peine
qui vous semblerait satisfaisante
moi j'ai peur qu'elle ait un contrecoup
en fait bien sûr
que ça fasse comme ce monsieur
j'ai pensé la même chose j'ai même pensé
à aller mal au cœur j'ai pensé à vie en
passant votre maman c'est pour ça qu'on
aime 50 prisons vous soyez très présent
avec je crois là vraiment peu de de faut
être honnête 90 ans donc autant qu'elle
est pas ce correctement donc ni l'argent
ni les excuses ni l'enfermement il faut
soigner ses enfants là ce qu'ils ont ces
enfants et à commencer aussi juste pour
soigner il faut que la société elle
trouve quelque chose pour soigner ces
gosses qui commencent à 3h30 si prenez 3
ans et demi de prison René est-ce que
pour vous ce serait une peine assez
assez forte donc il se fasse
moi je m'en fous de la peine je veux
vraiment que ça serve pour ses autres
enfants qui se sent comme ça et qui te
donne est-ce que est-ce que cantique
est-ce qu'après avoir fait ce peine ce
qui est jamais de la vie ils sont
récupérés ces jeunes ou est-ce qu'ils
vont empirer il va avoir encore plus la
haine j'en sais rien c'est la haine
quand même quelle est la solution parce
que quand tu arrives à des points comme
ça quand même ils sont ils sont vraiment
voilà
j'appelle pas ça de la délinquant c'est
de la violence quoi de la délinquance la
délinquance
prenez le sac je vais c'est pour tuer
les gens qui prend c'est c'est ça qui
vous a plu
le jeune il est il est baraqué
et ils l'ont suivi ils l'ont suivi
alors on va appeler l'effet pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent alors c'était
l'année dernière à 12h20 votre maman
donc rentre chez elle de course et puis
elle est agressée par derrière un coup
de poing à la tempe par un jeune donc de
14 de 14 ans il y en a un autre qui
filme et il y en a un qui lui vole son
sac pour quelques dizaines d'euros c'est
même pas 30 €, c'est ça
et elle est très choquée heureusement il
y a le gardien de la résidence qui est
là pour 30 euros 30 euros c'est fort
pour 30 euros alors
la vidéo surveillance et le lendemain la
famille de celui qui a porté les coups
le conduit au commissariat et puis les
deux autres sont interpellés dans la
foulée c'est la famille tous les cadeaux
voilà le conduit au commissariat où il
est interpellé et puis ils finissent par
reconnaître leur culpabilité ils sont
j'ai le 30 novembre par un tribunal pour
enfants et là ils sont placés dans des
centres fermés 3 villes différentes pour
pas qu'ils aient de contacts
et pourtant moi j'ai entendu dire je
sais pas sur quoi qui pouvait sortir
comme il voulait
c'est un centre fermé alors
qu'ils sont fiers pour eux c'est un
exploiter les vidéos sur google pour
dire voilà nous on revendique ça c'est
une sorte de revendication de filmer
pour montrer après
vous vous avez fait quoi etc les
couilles donc évidemment aucune excuse à
attendre de ce genre de personne prenez
et Alicia est-ce que vous avez peur pour
votre maman et votre grand-mère
aujourd'hui peur pour sa santé oui et
pour la pour la suite vous avez la suite
elle s'est rendu compte maintenant de ce
qui s'est passé
c'est pour ça que je voulais demander
qu'on la fasse déménager dans un truc
moi je voulais que le mode d'un peu à la
maison moi mais elle veut pas monter
elle veut pas avoir sexy
avec nous à la campagne
et elle veut pas pour le moment elle a
dit je monterai plus tard
ne veut et Ali il y a eu le contrecoup
après son agression il est décédé peu de
temps après
exceptionnel qu'est-ce que vous avez
envie de leur dire ce que vous avez vécu
un moment dramatique et allié il est
parti malheureusement après qu'est-ce
que vous avez envie de leur dire
aujourd'hui
en fait parce qu'on est toujours dans
l'émotion jusqu'à maintenant ça je pense
que ça partira pas après bon quand le
calme revient on réagit d'être plus la
même façon mais après comme j'ai dit
c'est sûr que sur le moment les mecs ils
sont là devant c'est bon moi je vous
remettez moi ces enfants là c'est la
même chose que vous je pense la même
chose si j'avais été là et ainsi de
suite sauf que là on parlait juste d'un
maire qui représente quand même
l'autorité
j'ai pas aimé son explication moi j'ai
adoré son expérience
avec quelqu'un l'enfant de quelqu'un
chaque personne a grossesse je vais tout
le monde c'est comme ça je vais vous
dire la vérité ça fait des années qu'on
est dans des discours langue de bois des
politiques ça fait des années et on voit
bien que ça ne marche pas c'est pour une
fois qu'on a un mec qui parle avec ses
tripes qui n'a pas dit faites-vous
justice vous-même c'est pas du tout ce
qu'il veut aujourd'hui
on a envie d'avoir des politiques qui
nous ressemblent aussi mais voilà alors
oui bien sûr il veut pas qu'on soit hors
la loi il veut pas qu'on se fasse juste
ici soi-même mais à un moment on lui a
posé une question sur Twitter et envoyer
la réponse parce que c'est un homme
avant d'être un élu c'est ce qu'il a dit
un homme s'entend pas un enfant de 14
ans de 90 ans je comprends pas
ce que c'est des mongole
qui se font agresser ça bouge plus vite
quand même
non là ça fait énormément parler
beaucoup plus et
là il y a une émotion considérable alors
il y a une émotion considérable
à ça j'espère que ça fera évoluer les
choses moi je suis très contente
on m'a dit que je pouvais dire ce que je
voulais je le dis hein
si vous voudriez dire ce soir voilà je
vous laisse carte blanche qu'est-ce que
vous voudriez dire sur ce qui s'est
passé en sortant là oui demain on va en
voir des grosses pages hein franchement
des grosses pages moi je suis contente
non vous avez des grosses pas toujours
content
de travailler j'avais peu d'espoir parce
que à la base il y a personne quand même
votre émission c'est super
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de dire de
nous dire ce soir déjà j'espère qu'elle
nous regarde on lui fait un énorme bisou
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de dire un
à ces agresseurs et de à votre maman
c'est pour moi c'est des petits cons
on voudrait juste que ça puisse
créer demain je serai content
alors je rappelle que c'est le c'est le
fils de la victime et pour un fils c'est
vrai que
oui pardon si je pense qu'il dit mais
c'est pas choquant ce qu'il dit c'est
choquant ce qui se passe effectivement
extrêmement touché parce
qu'effectivement au-delà des gens de 14
ans on y rajoute de la lâcheté et puis
effectivement ce qui est très important
de ce que vous avez dit mais je vous
laisse la parole c'est que on va
aujourd'hui on va au-delà de l'agression
on est si il y a une haine il y a une
haine bien sûr
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire c'est que tout
le monde c'est comme tout le monde
aujourd'hui
merci René
merci
nous on pense très très fort